les nouveaux créateurs d'entreprise ils
prennent la communication comme dépense
supplémentaire dans leur lancement de
l'entreprise or aujourd'hui nous ce
qu'on veut leur expliquer c'est que
c'est pas une dépense d'investissement
et que cet investissement était
nécessaire pour que leur société se
fassent connaître du public se fasse
connaître de leur cible et puisse leur
ramener une à une activité commerciale
parce qu'aujourd'hui si on n'est pas vu
si on n'est pas connu on risque pas de
vendre son produit on risque pas de
développer son activité alors on
communique intelligemment déjà en ayant
une analyse précise du domaine
d'activité dans lequel on est en faisant
un retour sur sa sur son entreprise en
analysant bien quelles sont nos cibles
et en sélectionnant et ça c'est plus de
notre c'est notre métier en aidant les
entrepreneurs a sélectionné les médias
dans lesquels ils vont ils vont se faire
connaître et communiquer au niveau du
budget c'est c'est difficile de donner
un chiffre comme ça ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que entre 2 et 5% du chiffre
d'affaires investis dans la
communication sait déjà c'est déjà un
budget qui est intéressant pour
commencer à travailler évidemment ça
dépend son domaine d'activité évidemment
ça dépend son chiffre d'affaires quoi
qu'il en soit il ne faut surtout pas
négliger cette partie là parce que elle
est essentielle pour le développement
que ce soit au départ d'une entreprise
ou même dans sa pérennité